and I'm not trying to be rude but I just
gotta look at what we pick so now this
has transitioned into chess tournament
so again you know there's no physical uh
strength needed in chess tournaments but
women are smarter than men right and the
average women are smarter than the
average men yet biological males have
been banned from competing in women's
chess competitions if we're so smart why
don't we just dominate why don't we just
kill it like we we just kill everything
right we're just so we're so um smart so
the comments say bro why is there even a
woman in a men's competition in the
first place Opus says because men are
more intelligent that's not even a
competition a three-year-old infant
could beat a woman Grand Master